i think now might be a good time to
address another question that's probably
circulating in your head and that is
what happened to the gold remember when
we started this reserve bank all of
these national banks or whatever we want
to call them they had gold as a reserve
and then at some point they said well
you know why are we each holding gold
why don't we just all concentrate our
gold in one reserve bank and then that
reserve bank can issue
and it was the only person that could
issue it could issue bank notes that
could be tradable into gold and then we
said we know over time
people just got used to the notion of
using the bank notes themselves that's
too thick
using the bank notes themselves
as reserves
and that's what the reserve ratios were
all based on were based on the bank
notes itself and we talked about that if
the fed or the reserve bank wanted to
increase the money supply it could
essentially just print new notes
print new notes and it would have
offsetting
notes outstanding
liabilities and then it could use those
to perform open market transactions and
it essentially allows it to grow the
monetary base with the economy or with
the needs of of different projects out
there so that those projects happen
and in that whole discussion we you you
might have noticed that this yellow
stuff was just sitting here it had
nothing to do with the economy it was
just sitting there and if you if you
really wanted to force me to say what it
was doing well it was giving a little
bit of confidence behind what this thing
was
right
it gives you a little bit of confidence
because at first at least when we said
you know that it was backed by the goal
there was maybe a similar amount of gold
as there was there maybe a little bit
later we said oh you know this could be
exchanged for gold at some rate maybe i
don't know 35 dollars per ounce i think
that's what it was when we were last on
the on the gold standard 35 dollars per
ounce
but if you think about it it's a couple
of weird things here first of all almost
from the get-go when we did this the
whole purpose of having this this
flexible money supply is so you can grow
and contract money with the needs of the
economy and we would for the most part
have notes outstanding because this was
a fractional reserve system we would
have notes outstanding more than the
actual amount of gold and this has been
the case even when we were on the gold
standard you had more dollars than you
actually had gold we had to keep a
little bit of gold there just so in case
people wanted to call your bluff in case
you know x percentage of the people
wanted their gold back so they would
come back to the central bank and say
give us our gold but the gold
fundamentally it had no other function
it had it wasn't in the economy it
wasn't helping transactions happen it
wasn't doing anything it was just
sitting in fort knox or wherever it
happens to be sid and
and and to some degree it was it's more
of a pain than any kind of real value
because
because you had to uh
keep up this notion that these things
these dollar bills could be translated
into gold it kind of forced a reserve
ratio requirement on the central bank
itself and that reserve ratio
requirement if you think about is kind
of arbitrary it's dependent on how much
gold is found in the world right in
order to increase the money supply with
gdp because you know people are
inventing computers and railroads and
cars and highways are being built and
we're all becoming more efficient in
order to keep the money supply up with
that extra economic activity we have we
if we stay on the gold standard if we
want to keep kind of these ratios
between the money and gold we'd have to
grow our gold with the economy and you
know that's kind of arbitrary you know
maybe we find a big bunch of gold or
maybe we find no gold and that really
should have no bearing on our
technological progress and how hard
we're working
and it makes a lot of time you could
imagine in a world where all of a sudden
you know an asteroid made of gold lands
on you know the middle of the us does
that all of a sudden you know because
gold is less valuable should that make
the dollar less cheap or in another
world where uh for whatever reason uh we
can't find any more gold should that all
of a sudden decrease our ability to
circulate money around and then when it
becomes and i said it three videos ago
that these dollar bills aren't just the
liabilities or the obligations of the
central bank
they're actually obligations of the us
government so let me ask you a question
would you rather have something backed
by gold or backed by the u.s government
and i know many of you
your gut reaction is a gold gold is real
value the us government what are they
good for they're a bunch of crooks
they you know they lie cheat and steal
they they you know they misallocate
wealth all of the time
but think about it gold as we said
before gold really isn't wealth it can
be used to represent wealth only because
it's pretty only because at some
period and it doesn't corrode at some
period in the past someone says oh i'm
willing to plow your field if you give
me that cool rock that you found that's
the only goal value gold has it can't do
work it can't be eaten it doesn't make
us more motivated it doesn't make us
happier it's not real wealth
not real wealth
now what about the us government
well it has the
the the right the authority to tax
and i know taxes are bad words and i
don't like them myself but it
essentially it can it can extract these
rents from the us economy right tax the
u.s economy
and u.s economy
that's real wealth that's labor
ideas land
resources everything that makes us tick
our our our labor our goods and services
our ability to educate ourselves and
innovate and come up with technology and
become more productive that's real
that's real wealth so if you really
think about i know i'm getting a little
abstract here but i want to i really
want to hit this point home because a
lot of people
i think are still under the notion that
somehow if something is somehow tradable
for gold that it is of a sounder
currency while if it's if it's an
obligation of a government with a very
dynamic economy but not gold somehow
less it's somehow backed by less wealth
but i'd argue that this is actually a
more
profound amount of wealth i mean we've
had currencies in in ancient history
that were backed by gold
but in a lot of cases you still had
inflation when you know the the spanish
currency in in
in the in the 15th century was backed by
gold but all of a sudden they discover
that you know central america had a lot
of gold and you had a ton of inflation
and that gold really didn't give any
real wealth to the spaniards at the time
it just made everything more expensive
for them it did allow them to buy a
little bit more from other countries but
it really didn't create any innovation
or any um any it didn't really make
their pie that bigger
except they did steal some pie pieces
from other parts of the world but we'll
leave that aside for now but this is
real wealth
a currency backed by a
a whole nation's ability to generate
wealth in some ways is a lot more
valuable but gold was a stepping stone
it was necessary because in order to get
this whole thing started in order for
people to really have trust
in
in this currency
just the way people are trained to think
you had to originally sell them on gold
right so if you think about it gold
didn't play any role so in 1971 when
richard nixon decides to go off of the
gold standard
if if and this is a big if if you trust
the government's ability to manage
to manage the money supply effectively
that they're not going to print so much
money that we have hyper inflation
or they're not going to print so little
money that we end up with you know a
deflationary spiral if you trust the
government's ability to do that it
really doesn't matter that we went off
of the gold standard and it really just
kind of gets rid of a little nuisance
and if you actually look at the federal
reserve's balance sheet today there
still is some gold sitting on their
balance sheet because it was really not
obvious what they what they what they
needed to do with it so they just kept
it
but anyway we'll talk a lot about this
uh you know what is wealth and what
isn't wealth and in the future one
example i often tell people is if if you
were
let's say your your plane is going down
you know you're the pilot of a plane
you're the pilot of a plane and it's
it's going down it's burning
you know you might see the it's burning
and you see two islands in the horizon
and you have to ditch your plane on one
of those islands so one of those islands
it just has a big pile of gold on it
right it has a big pile of gold and then
another island
you can see with your telescope from the
plain it has cows on it
it has cows on it it has i don't know
all these all these random fruit trees
on it with these luscious fruits you see
i don't know it has a big random pool of
i can't draw oil because oil is black on
a blackboard it has a pool of oil it has
another big nice lake of fresh water
that's away from the oil so it doesn't
get contaminated and it has and you can
even see from your telescope that has a
bunch of hard-working innovative smart
people on it
who can i don't know do all sorts of
interesting things and and you see and
they have roads
they have roads and they have horses and
they have all sorts of stuff which
island would you ditch your plane on
assuming that you'll never be able to
get back to you know civilization well
the obvious answer is you'd rather dish
your island you're playing on that
island because that island has more
wealth
and so when we went off of the gold
standard i know it seems like this big
horrible thing in the whole scheme of of
the world and gold has become a lot more
expensive it's no longer 35 an ounce
it's you know whatever 700 or 800 an
ounce now so you might think oh there's
been all this inflation it would have
been great if we were on the gold
standard but think about what's happened
since 1971. other than some of this
excess credit that was given out maybe
over the last 10 or 15 years other than
these bubbles we've seen a tremendous
amount of innovation and we haven't seen
hyperinflation and and that's and and
that's all in the world of you can call
it a fiat currency a currency that's not
backed by any kind of hard asset it's
backed by
people's trust in the ability for the
u.s economy to support
debt on to to pay off the the value of
this currency
we'll talk more about that in the future
i don't want to get too circular in my
in my my conversations but i'll see you
in the next video i just want to touch
on that point that we are now off the
gold standard